dozens of iranian immigrants held
demonstrations in berlin against the
visit by iran's Foreign Minister
Mohammad Javad Zarif the protesters
accused her on of oppressing the Iranian
people they say Zarif and the Iranian
government cannot be trusted
particularly when it comes to
negotiations on the country's nuclear
program also they're just taking
advantage of the West to get relief from
the sanctions solution Tehran's new
government has gone to great lengths to
change Iran's image abroad but
addressing a think tank in Berlin he
sidestepped questions on why Iran has
blocked nuclear inspections emphasizing
instead Iran's right to peaceful nuclear
development he also stressed his
government's commitment to reaching a
full agreement with the international
community I believe we can do it by July
twentieth that is the first six month
and I believe we should do it and I
believe it's possible to do it and I
believe we can do it even faster earlier
sorry surprised observers by out rightly
condemning the murder of jews by the
nazis in stark contrast to Iran's
previous regime zari called the
Holocaust a horrifying tragedy that must
never be repeated but demonstrators
remain unconvinced negotiations on
Iran's nuclear program are set to resume
in two weeks